I swear I'll spend more time looking for the parts I need than actually building anything.
Hey what's happening guys in our last video we used an op amp TLO72 as a gain stage in an
oscillator. Today we're going to use a different op amp the LM386 as what it's intended for an audio
amp. So I don't know if this exactly fits into the classic circuits you should know mold but we're
going to show you how to set up an LM386 super easy using its internal gain to make yourself a basic
little audio amplifier. So the first thing we need to do to do that is we need an audio source.
I got all kinds of options for audio sources but I like to keep things simple and if you've been
watching the channel for a while you know my favorite IC of all time is the 555 timer. So I have set up
here a simple bi-stable 555 timer I'm sorry a stable 555 timer and it is oscillating at about a kilohertz
which we can take a look at here. The 555 timer as you know outputs a square wave but square waves
don't sound good you know frankly they're not good for speakers they're not really audio
they're actually digital. But what I've done here is I simply set up a low pass filter these are 150
ohm resistors one microfarad capacitors three stages should give us an approximation of a sine wave.
No we're not going to look at it on the scope because you know what very few people actually have scopes
and I want everybody to be to know that they can do these kinds of projects and experiments at home
you don't have to have a scope there's other ways so we're going to use this cheap Zotec ZT-M0
auto manual meter in frequency mode
and if we come up here and we put her on pin three you see we get 1.075 kilohertz close enough to
one kilohertz for government work and after our filter
well that's showing 16 hertz but that's not true that's just because the voltage is so low
so you're not getting anything there at all
yeah don't worry we're still getting it and I'll show you that as well
again without the use of a scope all we need is a speaker
so we'll plug the negative lead of the speaker into our negative rail and we'll touch its pin three
and you can hear the one kilohertz tone we'll touch it here after the first stage
it's much quieter more of a sawtooth
smoother it's a triangle wave there and now this is going to be extremely quiet
I don't know if you're gonna be able to hear it or not but there is sound there
so listen carefully and you should be able to barely hear the sine wave try and get this up
as close to the camera as I can here we go
there we go so that's our sine wave but the amplitude has been limited by our low pass filter
so what we want to do is we want to amplify it we're going to use an lm386 audio amplifier let's
be bop over to the computer and have a look at the data sheet
all right so here is the data sheet for our lm386 low voltage audio power amplifier
and we have it in the 8 pin dip package and there's some information tells you works on battery
operation with minimum external parts and that's the truth and a supply voltage of 4 to 12 volts which is
excellent we're going to be using that it has low quiescent current drain that means when it's not
active that's your your gain now your voltage gain here from 20 to 200 ours is going to be 20 which is
the built-in internal gain okay and then we have some applications here
what's ours going to be portable tape tv sound line drivers yeah just a small audio amplifier i guess they
don't list that here you can see the schematic of how it's built and if you take a look here
i mean what is it made up of
i know you're all yelling it's made up of transistors i know but check out how many transistors
are in here if i get them all one two three four five six seven eight nine ten transistors
one two possibly three diodes is that a diode that's strange one two three four five six seven resistors
so i mean that's pretty cool there's a lot of stuff there
come down here and you get your basic information there is our pin out
input minus input plus ground bypass blah blah blah
tells you what your pins are here inverting input non-inverting input
absolute maximum but we're going to roll on down here
to the application circuit typical application this is the lm 386 with an internal gain of 20
and this is what we are going to set up here today just super simple we're going to put it together and
we are going to make it work now you see this will be a non-inverting amplifier because the inverting pin
is grounded we have a volume control here on the non-inverting pin
other than that we have a nice big dc blocking capacitor going to our speaker a little filtering going
on here and that's all she wrote let's do it
okay i think we're ready to go and get started you can see we have our circuit diagram here and
there are three pins we will not be connecting one eight and seven one and eight are where you can
connect i believe it's a capacitor for uh external gain and then seven is a bypass that we're not going
to be using either so we shall bring in our circuit
and avail ourselves a lovely lm 386 who will it be who will be who wants to come out and play you okay
so you know ic's always have splayed legs
they make tools for this but hey we don't like tools just put them on your bench give them a little
bendy bendino and you're good
we'll put him way over here
all right so let's start by hooking up our power supply that's the pix that's the pittsburgh way to
say power power like former steelers coach bill cower car we have some nice breadboard jumpers the reds are too
long so we'll go with an orange
and that's pin six one two three four five this is pin six right here so pin six goes to power
the pin four is our ground
we use gray for ground
i just want to make sure that you're hooking your pins up correctly
that's why an old guy like me has one of these doohickeys on his head
okay so that's pin four that's that pin eight
is our output so let's grab a longish
connector
and go from pin eight
over to here
then we need a 0.05 microfarad why would you say 0.05 microfarad why would you do that
because now you got to make me do internal head math
it's 50 nanofarads i think i'm sure somebody will correct me if i'm wrong i don't probably don't have
50 nanofarad but i probably have 47 nanofarad
and you know what they say close enough for government work
unless of course you work for nasa in which case you should probably use
the specified value there's no reason
that i'm going to this way you could go that way it'll be just fine and now it says we need a
resistor to ground 10 10 what well since they put a k over here let's assume that's 10 ohms
so let's see if we got a 10 ohm
there's one we could twist 10 of them together if nothing else happens
100 10 r yeah
enough for government work
get that guy out of there
one reason to have three foot long leads so we'll just trim them a little bit
and there is our 10 ohm
resistor to ground
get in there come on all right 10 ohm resistor to ground next we need a large
capacitor we're going to use an electrolytic 250
microfaradays
i got 220
220 or 330
let's go 330 when you're doing capacitors you should always err on the size
caution 330
capacitors of course long leg positive
but i like to trim mine to the same length because that's how i roll
the same length so i'm going to go
and that guy
go there like that
yeah nice
okay pin two
which is our inverting input
also needs to go to ground
i'm looking for another
gray one here
come on
my fingers are far too large
to reach in there without some manner of assistance
so pin two
one two two and four
four two both going to ground
okay
okay there's our first mistake that's pin eight our output is in fact pin five
i know some of you guys are sitting there screaming at me
you put it in the wrong hole
not like i haven't heard that before
only one golfing of course
okay let's try this again here
pin five that's much better
and make sure yep going the right direction there
so next we need a 10k pot i have a 10k pot right here
get her to plug in nice and neat like
yeah success
that is
okay that is fully on
that's off
hopefully we'll put it about
halfway to start out with
so the middle pin our wiper needs to go to pin tree
one two three oh look at that
i almost got it right
story of my life
okay
and this one needs to go to ground
hey caramba i gotta find another gray ground pin in here
hey we got lucky
these cheap bread boards sometimes just require a little
massaging to get them to go in right
definitely want to make sure you have them seated properly
okay
and then this one is our connection
over
so
trying to see if i have
something of the proper length
not really
what we'll do
we'll take one of these
longer gray ones here
and we'll just give it the old bendaroonie
just like that
now
assuming that i put everything together properly
we should be good to go
oh
we must hook up our sprecker
spreckens the electronics
the negative
positive
and
the power
i'm putting about 5.5 volts in from my
bench power supply what do you think
will she make noise or will she go kablooey
one way to find out
okay seven eight and one are not connected
everything else is connected
and we have no sound
hmm
wiper pin three
pin six is positive
not getting warm
like this there
all right let's uh
make sure we are still oscillating
okay
you know why is that showing me 50 hertz
that hold on or something
what is going on here
well first problem was
i had it on square wave out
and not hertz in
so yeah we are still getting
our oscillation
good
but why
are we not getting
an output
to the speaker
what have we done wrong
hmm
all right i'm gonna shut off the power here
shut that off
all right let's have a think
all right pin one
not connected
pin two
connected to ground
pin three to the wiper
one two three
pin four one two three four to ground
pin five is our output
which goes to our blocking cap
and also
to this filter
pin six is our voltage supply
seven is not connected
eight is not connected
all right turn the power back on
i'm gonna put this guy over here
set for six volts dc
let's see
we are getting at the pins
five point two five point six two
and our power supply is showing five point sixty so that's good
all right let's look at six volts ac
and see what we're getting out
yeah we're getting oscillation out
as you can see
hard to do and not block the camera at the same time
well we were getting it or we're not getting it now
try and put it here
and here
no
now let's just connect the speaker
here
now you see
we're getting dc out
this should actually be blocking dc so
shouldn't get anything at all here
we've got an offset here because this is actually
the dc
all right
just for um s and g's
let's take out
our blocking capacitor
yeah if it's blocking
all of the dc we're not going to hear anything
so let's see what we get now if we turn it on
okay
still nothing
have a look here
yeah i'm seeing two and a half
hmm
to the data sheet robin
so unfortunately the data sheet didn't give me any clues
i guess it's not on right now
unless that pot's bad
uh resistance resistance resistance
10k pots we'll put it on
we'll be
reading zero
reading eight
close enough for government work.
Let's flip on the power supply again.
I'm going to take you out of here so you can see.
Oh.
Did you hear that?
Did you hear it?
It appears to be working.
Turn it up.
Well, ain't that a miracle.
All right, boys and girls.
I have no explanation of why it didn't work before, but now it works.
Anyway, the whole point of this was to show you how to set up the LM386 audio amplifier.
We set it up as prescribed in the manual for the internal 20x gain.
And after, I don't know, I just, I don't get it.
I don't get it.
But whatever.
Sure works.
I don't get it.
give me a thumbs up give me two thumbs up sometimes life's just a mystery that's it I'm out
peace I want to thank you all for watching and spending time with me today the community like
this is something that we can all be very proud of so again thank you very much for all your
support of learn electronics please feel free to check out the patreon page dollar month is all I
ask and really helps keep the channel alive we also have an Amazon shop where you can buy most
of the items that you see on here and there's a link to it down below